King shark versus gorilla grodd are you
kidding me all these suits shrink and
what is this smells so bad because it's
the one you used when you swam against
King shark I know King shark is
technically a bad guy but you should see
just wait when he fights garage spoiler
alert we should get going actually
that's this is goodbye
your guys perspectives at least hey
everybody is Charlie we got brand new
flash footage to break down its King
shark versus Grodd like they've been
hyping up all season long ever since
comic-con actually so just a reminder
that the episode is not airing for three
weeks the episode is gonna be on March
5th so will explain what's going on but
obviously there's a lot of Easter eggs
like that Norah seen from episode 1 so
we'll do a new round of that blast ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave your favorite
king shark or Grodd moment on the video
the funny thing about that Nora scene is
that they very purposefully built that
in to hype up this episode knowing that
they would be doing it they actually
said at comic-con that they've been
trying to do more king shark more Grodd
episodes for a long time but the big
problem that's prevented them from doing
more of that in previous seasons is that
by the time they get to like the last
big block of episodes like this is gonna
be episode 15 so there's 23 episodes in
a season so there's not that many after
this and they have to wrap up their last
big cicada arc and they have to wrap up
the reverse-flash arc and push that big
teaser into crisis on Infinite Earths so
by the time they get to this part of the
season they're usually busy doing more
bigger important story stuff and they've
run out of money in their budget because
they're dedicating it to their really
big story arcs and a lot of times the
villains that they have our
special-effects heavy like zoom or savat
are required a lot of special effects a
lot of practical effects a lot of CG
special effects all over him so any time
they do really cool stuff like that in
episodes it takes money away from other
potential episodes where they could be
using it like king shark versus Grodd so
whatever it is they did with the budget
this season with all the different
episodes they found the money to
actually do this which is probably why
it's not a two-parter otherwise they
would had to spend way way more money
the funny thing about the episode too is
that you can't find any kind of episode
description anywhere they haven't
released one but the premise is all you
need
king shark versus Grodd welcome to the
jungle every gorilla pun every Jaws pun
you could possibly think of the way
north talked about it in her teaser she
was like I know King shark is a villain
but just wait till he fights Grodd makes
it sound like he's actually doing
Suicide Squad stuff working for Argus
trying to reduce his sentence because
he's still been locked up there ever
since the end of season 3 the fact that
they have a shot of Argus with a giant
water pipe in it in the basement there
just leads me to believe that he's been
chilling out there this whole time the
last time they actually did him in an
episode though was at the end of season
3 when they were keeping the special
dominators device locked up in his cell
they were forcing him to protect it
because it was so dangerous and they
figured that nobody was stupid enough to
try and steal something from king shark
cell because they basically gave him
carte blanche anybody comes in this cell
you're free to chomp their heads off
lalla totally did not count on the
brazen stupidity of the flash or Captain
Cold that was his famous planned speech
smart snart
I'm gonna keep hacking away and find out
for sure do you have any idea what else
might be down there doesn't matter
they're only four rules you need to
remember make the plan execute the plan
expect the plan to go off the rails
throw away the plan follow my lead and
you'll be fine so I guess King shark has
just been chilling out there reading
books doing whatever it is they let him
do in his cell the funny thing about
Grodd is that he was also being kept in
one of those other Argus cells on that
same block as king shark when beer and
Captain Cold went there at the end of
season 3 the reason why Grodd went to
legends of tomorrow last season was
because the reformed Legion of Doom
plucked him out of time and sent him
back to the Vietnam War so that he could
just wreak havoc at the end of that
season the time Bureau captured him and
sent him back to his cell at Argus so
unless something really big happened
between the end of legends of tomorrow
season and right now on this episode
Grodd is probably still on that cell
block so either he breaks out or son
thing happens because you see him going
bull King Kong on top of this building
it looks like he's wearing his armor at
least the helmet that he had during
season 3 when they had the big
two-parter gorilla City episode that was
when they got so lebarge helped to take
Grodd down because he's basically a good
or less psychotic version of Grodd
that'll listen to reason I don't know if
they're gonna do any soul of our stuff
during this episode because they're
really only a couple of ways the King
shark could defeat Grodd
because Grodd is about as strong as he
is but he's one of the most powerful
telepaths on the planet so the only way
the king shark could take down Grodd
would be if he had a lot of help from
team flash Wichita B looks like he gets
because Barry is wearing that special
defense mechanism on his brain so that
Grodd can't mind-control him King shark
would also have a decisive advantage if
he could get Grodd in deep water because
even though Grodd wouldn't immediately
drown he's probably a pretty terrible
swimmer and then obviously if they found
some way to protect king shark from
grodd's mind control ability really the
best way to take him down would just be
to get sole of ourself but he might not
be in the budget because they'd have to
have the money to do the CG first
character and they'd have to be able to
hire Keith David to do the voice
remember Keith David is the voice of
solovar which was really cool so levar
what I'm hoping the TV show does is that
really just offering king shark his
freedom in exchange for help and taking
Grodd down I'm hoping they don't try to
turn him back into a human
using that metahuman cure because
remember Caitlyn specifically mentioned
him when talking about the Cure itself
like they needed the cells of a person
that was not a metahuman before a big
dark matter explosion now King shark got
his powers a long time ago but he's
still just another dark matter metahuman
like most of the other ones on the TV
show the reason why Caitlyn is an
exception is because she got her powers
through vastly different means that had
nothing to do with dark matter when she
was a child so this way she's immune to
cicadas dagger and I also saw a lot of
questions about why Nora wasn't
susceptible to the effects of cicadas
dagger last night when they were all
working together that was the reason why
they were using killer frost frost blast
to sort of nullify the effects of the
dagger so that's why Nora ran through
her cold stream so that helped protect
her from the effects of the dagger there
was just like a lot of questions about
the logic of that big fight scene that
they had the reason why Nora is still
susceptible to the dagger is because the
dagger is dark matter based and Nora's
powers come from the Speed Force which
is just another form of dark matter what
I'm hoping is going on with the
reverse-flash
Nora plot is that as things slowly
continue on and get worse like things
with cicada just don't go the way that
the reverse-flash wants them to go he
starts to step in they barely defeat him
and then reverse-flash steals his dagger
and uses it for something special either
to escape or hopefully to create his
comic book scepter from the Silver Age
now they used it during the Jeff John's
rebirth era but it was more in like a
twist like remember this silly thing
that I had way back during the Silver
Age of comics well I'm gonna use this to
kill a whole bunch of people and then
goes on to use it to create the negative
Speed Force but that was during the Jeff
Jones rebirth era in the comics and they
haven't done any kind of negative Speed
Force stuff on a TV show yet so we'll
see because there was an Easter Egg
earlier this season during episode 1
when they talked about Nora using
reverse tachyons and they were slowing
her down
negative
negative tachyons so what instead of
speeding you up they slow you down yeah
oh damn I was just joking that's a real
thing yeah Ava and her team at the time
Bureau I have encountered them before
but no one knows where they come from or
how they're generated like Dark Matter
space-time continuum but it wasn't
really clear if they were trying to make
an easter egg for negative speed force
energy or anything like that because
that's like a whole other concept on the
show and there were a lot of people that
were looking at this Silence of the
Lambs style shot with you know Hannibal
Lecter reverse-flash sitting behind the
glass in Nora looking at him then saw
her face reflected in his chest and
wondered if that was meant to imply that
Nora would eventually turn evil or
something terrible would happen and she
would wind up going completely off the
rails there's a lot of crazy Nora
theories out there I think at most she
just winds up making things go
completely off the rails with the
reverse-flash and creating the
circumstances that lead to the
accelerated crisis on Infinite Earths
and it just winds up becoming the
biggest flash derp of all flash trips
like there were memes after Barry
started screwing with the timeline just
imagine the worst possible nightmare
version of that with Nora in reverse
flash it's a little too soon to tell
what future face they might put on
reverse flash if he lives up to his
promise from the crossover last year
when he's like I wonder what face I'll
be wearing next time we meet flash they
usually start building in teasers for
the next season like hey this stuff is
coming up in the last couple of episodes
of the season the other robic DC thing
that's happening this week is that Doom
Patrol episode 1 is dropping on Friday
on the DC streaming service so be sure
to check that out when you get a chance
it's really cool and really weird
congratulations Jamie sovereign you're
the giveaway winner from my last big
flash video but click here for all my
episode Easter eggs and click here for
brand-new Avengers and game in Captain
Marvel thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]